maintenant je vais alimenter le
ventilateur donc qui va servir pour la
cli m ch en jean et en licence
coordinateur de projet et objets
connectés au cfj de montigny le
bretonneux
après un bts électronique il a choisi de
suivre cette nouvelle formation proposée
par l'école connecté au futur de
l'industrie
son objectif monter sa propre entreprise
dans quelques années on apprend donc la
coordination donc gestion des équipes
savoir faire des réunions savoir fixer
des objectifs répondre à des appels
d'offres savoir négocier en plus de
formations en lien avec la domotique le
ca fille de montigny le bretonneux
permet de se former en électronique et
robotique mais aussi en réseau et génie
informatique
cette école de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie d'île de france accueille
350 jeunes apprentis
toutes les formations sont en alternance
pour les cycles de bts nous avons
effectivement une alternance d'une
semaine une semaine une semaine
entreprises une semaine au cfa sur les
cycles de l'école qui vont pas deux qui
vont de bac +2 à bac +5
l'alternance est différente puisque les
jeunes ont besoin d'avoir plus de temps
ou au cfa ou à l'entreprise pour pouvoir
développer des projets donc là
effectivement l'alternance peut aller
deux mois deux mois trois mois trois
mois quatre mois c'est un mois mais le
chantier d'installation la nouvelle
technologie
je trouverais c'était c'était pas mal et
puis je ne contrôlais sa maison à
distance et enfin où son bâtiment du
coup ça m'a beaucoup plu
des métiers d'avenir qui offre de
nombreux débouchés 80% des jeunes
trouvent un emploi dans les six mois
après l'obtention de leur diplôme